Trascrizione: Mohamed Badr
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Mia nonna era tutta particolare,
mica mi raccontava le favole.
Quando ero piccola,
andavamo sempre a Roma per Pasqua.
Zio Giorgio e zio Paolo facevano a gara
a chi faceva l’abbacchio più buono;
e noi, venendo da Milano,
eravamo ospiti di mia nonna.
Lei era molto religiosa,
e la sera non mi raccontava le favole:
mi raccontava le storie dei santi.
E io ero affascinata da questi personaggi,
perché facendo scelte coraggiose
avevano messo in discussione la loro vita.
Hanno compiuto qualcosa di speciale,
che ha cambiato il mondo.
E io sono cresciuta con il desiderio
di fare anch'io qualcosa di speciale:
anch'io volevo cambiare il mondo,
anche se non volevo diventare santa.
Quando ne parlavo con l'irruenza
di un'adolescente,
mi sentivo dire: "Sei un’idealista":
e per tanto tempo,
ho pensato che fosse sbagliato
avere un'aspirazione così alta,
e l'ho lasciata in sordina.
Finché un giorno
è riemersa, forte e chiara.
Come coach avrei potuto, nel mio piccolo,
fare tanto bene alle persone
e aiutarne tante
a fare qualcosa di speciale,
nel loro piccolo:
insieme, avremmo potuto cambiare il mondo.
Sono partita da me:
avevo 45 anni,
e la mia solita vocina
nella testa mi diceva:
“Ma dove vuoi andare? Hai già a 45 anni!”
E poi flebile, ma distinta,
ho sentito un'altra vocina:
"Hai solo 45 anni!"
Quando sono andata dal mio trainer,
e gliene ho parlato,
lui mi ha fatto un'unica domanda:
“A quale delle due
hai scelto di dar retta?”
È stato il primo incontro
consapevole con le sfumature.
Una piccola parola -
"solo", invece che "già" -
aveva fatto una differenza enorme per me.
Come nel golf,
uno scostamento impercettibile
dell'inclinazione del bastone,
durante lo swing,
può far sì che la pallina cada
dall'altra parte del campo,
anche decine di metri,
più in là o più in qua.
E oggi, è più che mai importante
avere una buona mira.
Il nostro mondo è sempre più diviso
tra chi ha paura e chi no,
chi si vaccina e chi no.
Chi lavora come mai prima,
e chi fa fatica.
Chi è ricco, e diventa sempre più ricco;
e chi è povero,
e diventa sempre più povero.
La pandemia avrà una coda lunga,
l'abbiamo capito tutti ormai:
e notiamo un aumento
dell'aggressività, della depressione,
dei conflitti, della solitudine
oltre che un significativo
impoverimento culturale dei giovani.
In questa prospettiva dicotomica,
siamo costantemente chiamati a scegliere.
E io ho scelto:
io voglio cambiare il mondo.
Non è un pensiero originale,
lo so: e meno male!
Perché siamo in tanti, oggi,
a voler costruire un futuro
più felice per il pianeta.
È un momento di svolta
tra pre e post pandemia,
un passato - quello dei miei genitori
e dei miei nonni - fatto di guerre,
e il futuro dei nostri figli
che, nel mio modello del mondo,
non può essere altro
che più green e sostenibile.
Per far questo serve fiducia,
creatività, passione.
Un progetto comune: spirito di squadra.
Ricordiamoci che veniamo
tutti dallo stesso posto,
e che stiamo andando tutti
nello stesso posto.
Cosa stiamo creando, oggi,
che rimarrà nei secoli?
Io non so fare miracoli:
ma so cogliere, e coltivare, le sfumature.
Le sfumature sono quelle piccole decisioni
nella vita di tutti i giorni
che fanno la differenza;
e come nel golf,
uno scostamento minimo
nella nostra percezione
ci può aprire scenari differenti
e portare a risultati
anche molto diversi nel lungo periodo.
E allora, giochiamoci un po’
con queste sfumature,
con un grande classico:
lui e lei a cena.
Lei, già giorni prima, chiama l'amica:
"Sai che sabato sera esco con lui?"
E poi parrucchiere, unghie, mise,
e si fa un film della serata.
Lui, a volte condivide anche lui.
Si veste fighetto, si cura la barba,
prenota al ristorante che anche lui
si fa un film della serata.
Quanti film ci siamo fatti?
Ora, il cervello è micidiale:
valuta costantemente una quantità
inimmaginabile di stimoli
per la nostra sopravvivenza,
e non ce ne rendiamo neanche conto.
Cosa succede nel nostro film
se, quando i due si incontrano,
lui le dice: "Sei bellissima",
lei apprezza la sua eleganza.
a cena ridono, scherzano, conversano
e la comunicazione fluisce
come in un tango?
Sempre giocando: cosa succede
se lui arriva in ritardo,
se la sua macchina
è un po’ troppo vissuta,
e se per tutta la sera parla solo di sé?
E dall'altro lato,
cosa succede se lei, quando scende,
ha un trucco un po’ pesante;
e subito gli fa notare
che c'è una via più veloce
per arrivare al ristorante,
e lo interrompe mentre lui sta dicendo
qualcosa che per lui è importante?
L'esito della serata
dipende dalle sfumature:
impariamo a coglierle, e a coltivarle.
Il segreto per coglierle
mi è stato passato
da un'amica, tanti anni fa:
è quando l'Io diventa tu.
Mettiamoci in ascolto con umile curiosità.
Per coltivarle, mi sono ispirata
al padre della comunicazione
non violenta, Marshall Rosenberg.
Mi ha insegnato ad ascoltare
non soltanto quello che la persona dice,
ma anche quello che la persona non dice:
l'intenzione, le emozioni,
i bisogni, le aspirazioni.
Ora vi voglio dimostrare
come l'ascolto può fare
la differenza nella nostra vita.
Ho scelto tre sfumature,
per me le più importanti.
La prima l'ho incontrata in autostrada.
Quando chiedo alle persone cosa vedono,
normalmente mi rispondono: macchine,
autostrada, cartelli, nuvole, montagne.
Ok.
Ma la domanda più importante
è cosa non sto vedendo.
Questa sfumatura mi è stata utilissima,
nella gestione del conflitto.
Appena c'è qualcosa che non va,
noi puntiamo subito il dito sull'altro.
È lui il responsabile,
è l'altro che non dice, non fa, non pensa,
non è quello che vogliamo noi.
E così, il focus è sì sull'altro,
ma solo perché non soddisfa
un bisogno nostro:
in realtà, il focus è su di noi.
In una discussione tra soci,
in un team di lavoro, in una coppia
noi vediamo quello che è apparente;
ma non sappiamo mai cosa l'altro
sta pensando, provando, vivendo.
E quando ci si accalora, l'altro a volte
comincia a vomitarti addosso:
non soltanto il problema contingente,
ma già che c'è anche tanto altro.
E parte una discussione
in cui ognuno vuole avere ragione:
ma quando anche ti ho dimostrato
che ho ragione, come mi sento?
Davvero penso di aver vinto?
E l'altro come si sente?
Siamo più vicini o più lontani?
Rosenberg propone una via alternativa,
a questo approccio antagonistico.
Mettiamoci in ascolto di quel tanto altro,
con l'intenzione di scoprire
qual è il bisogno non risolto
che non stiamo vedendo.
Perché tutto quello che facciamo,
lo facciamo per un motivo,
per soddisfare un bisogno;
e i bisogni fondamentali sono universali,
anche se non tutti li sentono
con la stessa intensità,
nello stesso momento.
Smettiamo di giudicare,
e invece impariamo a comprenderli.
Insieme, poi, negozieremo la strategia
più efficace per soddisfarli.
Come?
Con una metafora.
Io la chiamo il secchio del vomito.
Chiedo scusa se, magari,
siete un po’ delicati di stomaco:
Ma tu sai benissimo:
se hai avuto una crisi di vomito
mai nella tua vita, quanto dura?
Un minuto? Due minuti? Non di più.
Allora, quando l'altro comincia
a vomitarci addosso,
porgiamogli un bel secchio,
gli bagnamo la fronte,
qualche parolina di conforto;
ma senza metterci a giudicare
e senza discutere.
Ha bisogno di sentire che ci siamo.
Quando poi sta meglio,
quando l'emotività è scesa,
a quel punto mettiamo da parte il secchio
e insieme possiamo andare
alla scoperta di che cosa gli serve.
Magari non era così chiaro prima,
e insieme possiamo trovare una soluzione.
Questa sfumatura mi è molto cara,
l'ho vissuta come figlia e come mamma.
I genitori sorreggono i bambini
quando stanno imparando a camminare;
scorgono i loro talenti
e vogliono aiutarli a esprimerli;
vedono gli ostacoli prima di loro,
e vorrebbero proteggerli.
E così, in questo rimpallo tra:
“Te lo sto dicendo
perché l'ho vissuto prima di te”,
”Ma mami, i tempi sono cambiati”,
”Vedrai se non avevo ragione”
“Non ammetterò mai che avevi ragione”,
rischiamo di perderci
la sfumatura più importante,
una connessione al livello più profondo.
I nostri figli hanno bisogno
di sentirsi amati
perché esistono:
non per quello che sanno,
non per quello che ottengono.
Nel film Avatar dicevano: “Io ti vedo”.
Io sono una mamma adottiva,
e pensavo che il mio amore
sarebbe bastato a colmare il vuoto.
Se non a cancellare,
almeno mitigare il dolore.
Ho affrontato tanti ostacoli,
e come tutti i genitori
ho fatto degli errori.
Oggi, quando ci vediamo è un incontro.
Io mi metto in ascolto,
delicatamente curiosa.
Loro mi raccontano, io mi racconto.
Nelle lunghe chiacchierate che facciamo,
mi lasciano intendere
che la nostra connessione
si sta rafforzando.
Questo basta a rendermi felice:
poi, le somme le tirerò alla fine.
Questa sfumatura è meno intuitiva,
ma è quella che fa la più grande
differenza in assoluto.
A partire dagli anni 90,
il Dartmouth Institute in California
ha effettuato numerosi studi
neuroscientifici sulla coerenza cardiaca,
e ha dimostrato che il cuore è molto più
che un efficiente pompa
che permette la vita.
Oggi sappiamo che
il cuore ha un suo cervello,
proprio i suoi circuiti neurali;
e che è in grado di imparare,
ricordare, decidere e sentire
indipendentemente dal cervello.
Il cuore ci apre una fonte
di intelligenza e saggezza,
ci aiuta a sviluppare
creatività e intuizione.
Io l'ho sperimentato in prima persona,
e ho scoperto un modo
diverso di ascoltare.
La mia relazione con mio papà
è stata molto conflittuale,
quando ero un'adolescente impetuosa,
A 19 anni, un'amica mi disse:
"Sai, io non ho fatto in tempo
a fare pace con mio padre".
Quella frase mi ha inseguito
per tutta la vita.
Ogni incontro che diventava scontro,
mi lasciava l'amaro in bocca;
e io mi scervellavo, letteralmente,
per cercare un modo diverso per fare pace.
Ci sono riuscita
quando ho smesso di cercare
chi avesse ragione,
e ho ascoltato quello che avevo nel cuore.
Oggi sono felice per come è evoluta,
e come sta ancora crescendo,
la nostra relazione.
Ci scontriamo ancora, ma a ping pong.
Ho imparato che il cervello
vuole avere ragione;
il cuore sa.
Sarà capitato anche a te
di prendere una decisione
dopo aver vagliato tutti i pro e i contro,
decisione che poi si rivela sbagliata
e tu senti quella vocina che dice:
"Lo sapevo, che dovevo fare
nell'altro modo."
Ecco, il cuore sapeva.
Ho condiviso tre sfumature:
chiedermi cos'è che non sto vedendo;
ricercare una connessione;
e ascoltare il cuore.
Ovviamente, le sfumature sono più di tre:
e sono anche più di cinquanta.
Ogni volta che siamo davanti a una scelta,
mettiamoci in ascolto,
sintonizziamoci sull'altro con umiltà.
Così potremo fare qualcosa di speciale,
e così potremo cambiare il mondo.
E cominciamo dal prossimo incontro
che abbiamo con una persona.
Ci vediamo, ci sorridiamo, ci salutiamo.
Sento la sfumatura emotiva quale che sia.
Cosa scopro che non avevo visto prima?
Forse non è così importante avere ragione.
Cos'è che gli serve per stare meglio?
A fare tutta la differenza
è un "Io ti vedo"
Ora ti invito a portare questo valore
in tutti i tuoi incontri
della prossima settimana,
del prossimo mese, del prossimo anno.
E immagina che tutte le persone
per cui tu avrai fatto la differenza
faranno lo stesso
nei loro giorni successivi,
nelle settimane successive,
nei mesi successivi.
Vista così, cambiare il mondo
è un attimo, ti pare?
Grazie nonna.
(Applausi)